william is with us in jackson
mississippi
hi william welcome to the dave ramsey
show hey dave how are you
better than i deserve what's up um
so i'm planning on graduating from
college in the next
uh this time next year actually
congratulations
i'll be debt free from student loans wow
i won't have a
home and i have a full full-time job
that's lined up for this time next year
starting at about 75
000 a year with 401k options and
benefits
good my question is what should i
do when looking for getting a new house
or starting
look for my first home um
currently i want to live outside the
city limits because the
inner city texas where i live is
tremendously
larger than it would be in outside the
city limits
so what do you suggest i should do for
my first house
okay well you've established one thing
you want you know what you want you want
to be outside the city
um the first thing i would tell you is
you don't have to be in a hurry
um i'm okay if you wait a year or two uh
i don't want you to be a renter your
whole life but you are not
being like crazy man or you're not
stupid or something by not buying a
house immediately
because the first couple years out of
college is when is one of the most
transitional times of most people's
lives
new jobs new relationships all kinds of
things going on
and a home is a very permanent
type decision it's something that's not
easy to undo you can buy a car and get
rid of a car pretty easy about
you know by the end of the week right
but a house you you buy it you're gonna
you know it takes a little while to get
rid of that thing if you've got the
wrong one or something
and so um you know first thing i would
do is not buy for the first six months
out of school
maybe the first year out of school and
maybe even more is okay but at least
six months between six months and a year
is fine
somewhere in there the second thing then
is when you get ready to buy a home
take your time in searching and really
researching
it's a large purchase and
when we teach business people and
leadership decision making skills
one of the things we teach them is he
with the most
options and the most information
wins the negotiation and wins a good
decision
if you look at two houses and you pick
one out that's like going on a
date with a girl two times and getting
married
okay and so you know you don't want to
do that we want to take our time
get to know this area look at several
properties
um i'm looking at a second home
situation right now and i probably
looked at
60 properties in that area of course i
enjoy it i'm a real estate guy but
uh i look at a lot of properties i
learned their square foot prices i
learned
you know where the uh the popular side
of the tracks is
and the popular side of those tracks is
and down into the cul-de-sacs and what's
the differences
and i want to learn and learn and learn
and learn to learn learn learn and learn
learn and then you'll make a better
decision